a former chemical engineer an investment
banker he is the founder of Vista Equity
Partners in 2018 with a net worth of
five billion dollars he became the
wealthiest african-american in the world
surpassing Oprah Winfrey he recently
decided to pay off the entire student
loan debt of the 2019 Morehouse College
graduating class of three hundred and
ninety-six students he's Robert F Smith
and here's my take on his top ten was a
success vol 2 enjoy okay let's kick it
off with rule number one wanted badly
enough when I was coming through I had a
great group of classmates and they were
actually introducing computers for the
first time and so my computer instructor
was telling me about I was to ask him
well how does this actually work and was
something about the transistor and you
know was developed at this place called
Bell Labs and I found out there was one
in Colorado so Denver Bell Labs and I
called him I said I'd love to get an
internship do you have and they said yes
if you're between your junior and senior
year in college I said well that's great
I'm a junior in high school taking AP
classes just like being in college they
said well no it isn't and I said well
you know I'd love an internship and so I
called every day for two weeks they
stopped taking the call after the second
day and I called every Monday for about
five months and one day they called back
and said a student from MIT didn't show
up we have an extra slot and if you'd be
interested
we're not guaranteeing your job you can
come an interview because remember they
never met me as I put on the one suit
that I owned and put two dollars in mine
of gas in my car and drove out there and
got the job and basically work there for
the next almost three and a half four
years as an intern while I matriculated
with my degree at Cornell I think they
appreciated the fact that I really
wanted that job and I really wanted to
you know better myself
rule number two create an environment of
innovation you have to be thoughtful
about creating an environment where new
ideas of innovation are not only welcome
but they're encouraged they're embraced
and the success of them are trumpeted
sure because otherwise you you you have
the risk of like all things you know the
complacency factor you know leads it
leads you down a narrowing Road of
opportunity and look I face it with my
own firm now eighteen years you know
seventeen
eighteen years in the making how do we
make sure we don't atrophy on what we
were good at and oh by the way how do we
ensure that we continue to evolve our
culture on the one hand and expand our
business opportunities in the markets
that we're in rule number three take
risks you're doing very well out there
you're now living in San Francisco area
you're making a big success you're by
investment banking standards I presume
you're you know highly compensated so
forth what propelled you to say I'm
gonna give all this up and go start my
own company
right so the interesting thing that
occurred as you know again as an
engineer the thing I realized way back
in my Goodyear entire in rubber days the
impact that software really had on
businesses the thing that I noticed that
there's very few software companies were
actually efficiently run well why the
big part was most executives who started
software companies well they wrote code
or they knew a market opportunity and
they sold the code there was never
anyone who taught them how to run
software companies so I didn't run into
this the small company I'll say small in
in Houston Texas that is the most
efficient software company I've ever
seen they had some very basic things
that they just did extremely well and I
said well if you took those basic things
in and actually applied them ultimately
to other enterprise software companies
you could run those businesses very
similar to the way they ran theirs and
would create tremendous value in those
companies that that was the idea that
was a conceit and they said that's a
good idea why don't you do it well yeah
in essence I said well if you actually
thought about taking some of these best
practices and putting them buying
enterprise software companies and
driving them forward you could actually
do pretty well and I said that's a great
idea would you do that and I said well
you know they gave me one of those
offers that looked quite interesting and
I remember my lawyer said this is a bad
deal Robert but you should take it yeah
right so you went to Goldman and said
I'm leaving right they try to talk you
out of it of course they made the pitch
against it but you know I like all
things David at some point in time in
your life you know you got to look
yourself in the mirror and said you know
you have to take a little risk and go
see if this is how old were you when you
took this I was 39 years old and it's so
interesting so of course I started doing
research it was the same age that others
left what they were doing to go start
their businesses I said well let's go
give
to run rule number four be purposeful
how do you make sure you make a change
in the world and your community
leveraging your profession no if you're
an engineer there are certain things you
can do if you're a teacher there are
other things you can do with different
things you can do and I think it's
important that I say you know you pick a
pick a cause and have an effect as
opposed to meander without direction and
just kind of glance through different
sets of economic opportunities but pick
a cause and make an effect so be
purposeful that's what I really want the
message to be also if you want to learn
from other leaders in the black
community check out my 254 block
excellence program it's free the link to
join is in the description below you can
actually make more money being smart
than you can being strong or fast
running your own race demands trusting
yourself even when others don't rule
number five create a peer network it is
important to have certain philosophies
in managing your business there's a
couple that I use I'm going to focus on
one here one is I call the principle of
self replication right because you all
will pretend that oh I'm the best
representative of every person in my
company and they should act just like I
would act there's a problem with that
okay because you actually aren't the
best person in that job because it
evolves and all those sort of things so
you actually have to create what I call
space and volume for people to fill with
who they are and this is the principle
that I call you know you need to create
a platform where people can become their
best selves ok and becoming your best
self is not only understanding why we're
doing what we're doing but you have to
have room for them to contribute their
capabilities into your ecosystem and
into that ecosystem where it can now
evolve into a better a better solution
for the collective and then you have to
have mechanisms by which that naturally
occurs for instance I have these things
called B P SSE's best practice sharing
summits every month somewhere on the
planet our top 300 400 executives by
function are getting together ok for two
or three days and it might be sales
marketing GNA whatever it might be and
in those 2 or 3 days you know of 50
portfolio companies there'll be you know
400 people in sales you know
regional sales reps you know national
sales rep etc and they're gonna teach
and train each other on these best
practices over two and a half in three
days and so those who are doing the
teaching of course now have the ability
to what I call Express the refinements
and express how they've actually
implemented some of these best practices
and how they've been effective those in
the audience who've just joined the
portfolio we've just bought the company
okay now have a chance to participate
and see and learn and hopefully becomes
aspirational because it usually does
they said man you know in a year or two
or three years I want to be the one up
there teaching my colleagues and then
you create a peer mentoring Network it's
very different entrepreneurs as you
probably know as if you're executives I
mean it's a lonely environment it's a
lonely world who do you talk to right
well if you think about you're in a
company of 200 employees of five you're
running sales and services well who is
your peer group who do you talk to about
some question that you have where
there's not a conflict so I like to
think that we don't like being Dean it
kind of get here it's a lonely job right
you know what you know talk to your
president lovely wonderful smart and
helpful but you said pick you out if you
don't do something do it but that's an
interesting thing right you know and so
for you entrepreneurs in this audience I
would also recommend YPO young
presidents organization if you could
join that and then the more important
part of YPO people tell you the
networking all that that's nice but the
important part of it is actually your
forum okay in forum is where you pick
six or eight people or they pick you
they have to be in a business it's
non-conflicting and then you will always
say oh I don't have time for this and
you find out that's the best time you've
spent that month because you can
actually now talk about ideas you people
need to have some peer-to-peer network
and mentoring and you know engineering
school gives you that in in some
respects at that level and that's an
important part of the refinement
ultimately as an entrepreneur and an
executive is to create a peer network to
engage with rule number six think
differently we are truly in the the
early stages of the fourth Industrial
Revolution there is a digitization of
every single industry
on the planet and ultimately that will
lead to the digitization of every single
company in one way shape form or another
we have these talks about oh you know
everybody wants to be a king right no
you actually want to be an emperor okay
and that's what Bezos has done hmm if
you think about it because now you can
actually you know disintermediate entire
industries if you have the right
platform the next thing I think about is
you know what creates you know as a as a
chemical engineer I like to think about
the world in states of equilibrium what
is the next state of equilibrium in an
industry so that's the next lens through
which I look at an industry and if you
can do that you're gonna know what's
gonna participate in that ecosystem of
equilibrium and what is no longer
necessary for that ecosystem to remain
in equilibrium mm-hmm okay so to a great
extent if you take the insurance
business well do you need underwriters
or do you just need underwriting okay
and then you have to ask yourself well
do you need underwriting or do you
actually need to just have some way to
manage risk okay and then you say well
on the investment side of the house do
you really need investors to manage that
risk or you just need to match assets
with the liabilities over dated future
so think about the equilibrium states
what is going to be the equilibrium
state that has that can be achieved
leveraging current elements of
technology which have now accelerated
through true machine learning true
artificial intelligence and through true
cognitive development associated with it
you see it I mean let me give an example
if you are in the automotive business
and you are a very large-scale
automotive company and you make cars or
you make trucks you participate and only
one slice of that industry but the
equilibrium of that industry is going to
be supplied by the parts it is a short
chain the supply chain of the changes
all of an acid yeah right but you can't
control that whole ecosystem so as if
from an opportunity perspective the way
we think about it is how do we become
leaders in the ecosystem as opposed to
participants in the silence so that's a
give you a sense for where we go and how
is he
and way to think about it rule number
seven connect with nature you're a big
fly fisherman I love it yes I'll tell me
what the appeal is because you have a
big brain and you're trying to outsmart
a small brain so why is that so common
is it because those little brains are
actually focused on outsmarting you
because you're in their territory but
the beauty of it honestly David is
nature you're standing I think about it
you know all things in this world that
we live in today depend upon water
in order to live I think about water as
being in essence the literal lifeblood
of this planet and you're standing in
this water with your feet on the soil
and the water is resting around you and
at some point in time if you open
yourself to it all things become one and
you stand there and you start to realize
that you were part of this greater this
greater consciousness of existence and
this is the fly-fishing is just a way to
stand in the water without looking
ridiculous rule number eight study the
market I think it's critically important
to always be aware of you know the the
competitive dynamic in your market but
not aware of it just in a point of fear
but in a point of Education you should
you should make sure you were continuing
to inform yourself as to where your
market is going and don't be so
egotistical to know that you think that
you know everything but to be open
yourself to to be getting informed on
where your markets going rule number
nine get knowledge I just remember
growing up and call a recent recently
desegregated schools in in Denver and
you grew up in a predominantly black
neighborhood there was a Japanese family
that lived around the corner and I'd
know why they lived there if you think
about you know how they were Japanese
Americans were treated during the war
etc but you know we had our own grocery
stores and own doctors and I had lived
next to the lieutenant governor of the
state who was black in two state
senators state senator who was a
representative who was black but I
looked at how we live
said you know everyone tells me
education is the key and it wasn't bad
but I could tell the kids that who I
went to school with lived a whole lot
differently than we did and none of
their parents had PhDs right so I said
something there's a gap here and I
wanted to understand what that was so
that's what led me to actually think
about you know what is it it isn't just
education that's a part of it there's no
question but it's access to opportunity
access to mentorship
access to know-how and it gets back into
that intellectual property piece you
know it's knowledge you know I tell
people in America we have really six
exports all of our intellectual property
based at the end of the day its
knowledge and insights and information
that if you don't have that no matter
and some respects how much capital how
much desire you have it's going to be
hard for you to move along the the
wealth chain and expand the opportunity
set for yourself in the family and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is give back why do
you decide to become such an active
philanthropist in just a few years I saw
my mother write a $25 check to the
United Negro College from every month
growing up and even when I wanted a new
pair of you know converse all-stars
she said go earn the money to get them
yourselves as he wrote that $25 check
which I could have bought two pairs with
you know she instilled in me the
importance of giving to the community I
saw my father who was on the board and
ran you know the local YMCA is at East
Denver YMCA and I know how he
contributed time and energy and in
intellectual capacity on raising funds
so the kids in our neighborhood could go
and spend you know camps or summer camp
and enjoy the outdoors and understand
the importance of the outdoors and
building one's sense of spirit and one
soul so all through my life growing up
you know philanthropic endeavors were
part of my family my family dynamic now
I've got a special bonus clip from
Robert on how to seize opportunities
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing question it's time to go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go
question number one how will you give
back this week number two what knowledge
do you need to invest
yourself and number three how can you
create a peer network so you're not
alone if you travel the world like I do
and I probably go to you know 40 50
countries a year you start to really
understand that this is one of the few
places where we have on ramps to
opportunity to other places don't and in
some cases you know we don't see those
on ramps as prevalent in our communities
and so part of what our role here kids
is to force those on ramps to to emerge
and and create them when we can and and
and demand them when they are with help
and so part of what the elders of this
community have to do is make sure that
they are never silent in demanding those
on ramps and part of you as youth have
to understand is when those on ramps
become present to take advantage of
every step along the way because there
has been a lot of blood sweat tears and
literal blood to put those on ramps and
make them available for you to launch
into what is the greatest economic
opportunity on the planet which is in
America
if you want more roberts-smith check out
the first top-10 I get on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
you can actually make more money being
smart than you can being strong or fast
running your own race the man's trusting
yourself even when others don't